All right, YouTube. Andrew. We're over
here at TruckMax
Scottsdale. We're going to be
programming a remote for this
2015 lifted Silverado HD
Z71 with
our
trusty Advanced Diagnostics MVP Pro. So,
should be a lot of fun here, guys.
I'm going to climb up in the truck and
we're going to get started on
programming a
uh Chevy
remote. Stay
tuned. All right, guys. So, we got the
MVP Pro out. We're going to program the
remote for this 2015
uh Silverado.
So, we go down to GM USA, go to
remote. You can go by vehicle.
Chevy,
Silverado,
2500,
2015. Some of the older models of this
you didn't need to plug in. You could do
some onboard programming. With newer
ones, you
cannot. We have the smart card, which is
up here. I don't know how much of this
you guys can see, but we're going to
just try it and find out. So, we hit
enter after we switch ignition on
So, you hold both buttons down for up to
8 seconds. You hear the beep, that means
it's done. Hit
enter. And that's it. We're
done. Turn it
off. Open the door up.
Now we got all the way around. Check the
remote
start. Remote start is
good. And that's how you program it with
a MVP advanced
diagnostics. Hey guys, if you like my
YouTube channel, please subscribe below.
Below it's over here. I don't know. It's
somewhere anywhere. It's wherever they
like to put it. I don't know. But thank
you guys for watching. Please subscribe,
tell your friends, share my videos. If
you have any questions, email me
andrewslockkey
aazgmail.com or don't hesitate to pick
up the phone. I answer my phone all the
time.
480437422. Thank you and have a great